you beautiful driving Wow distracted we
partnered with Kia Forte to test our
concentration while behind the wheel
we're gonna try to drive a ridiculous
course filled with distractions while
not being distracted somehow seems like
all of technology and social media is
driven towards making us not pay
attention to anything that's actually in
front of us you got your apps going you
got your notifications you got your tabs
open I got retweeted that's exciting but
first we're gonna talk to a
neuropsychologist to find out just how
distracted we are I am a clinical
neuropsychologist that's someone who
really focuses on brain structure and
connectivity and how it influences your
behavior what are the tests we'll be
doing today to assess our attention one
you're gonna try to sustain your
attention and focus another one you're
gonna be switching between different
kinds of thinking we have to do this for
20 minutes he sounds so defeated I hate
this 'ready get set I think my worst
focus is in like duration focus like
when I read a book I normally get five
pages in and realized I haven't read the
last two pages oh God
as a kid I was distracted by things
because I was such a creative but I was
relentlessly told not to be distracted
to scratch my face but I won't if I have
a quiet location with no distractions
I'm very good at focusing how's it going
certainly having OCD growing up I was
always concentrating on things that
other people weren't concentrating on my
mind is different you're trying to beat
me and there's no point in that nag you
performed at the 91st percentile Eugene
you were at the 75th percentile Keith
you were at the 63rd percentile 63
that's me and then that I don't like
that those numbers get lower you were at
the thirty seventh percentile this is
every video we've ever done ever
so we're back from the brain doctor and
she told us that Ned was actually the
most focused so Ned you get to go first
I've got the most to lose before we do
it with all the distractions we're gonna
run the course dry so we have a control
this is science ladies and gentlemen
barely science I consider myself a very
good driver when you're driving with
precious cargo you have to be very
precise very careful just look at all
those cones they're asking to be hit
look that's one
oh this is so fun when it comes to
driving I've always been very very good
at keeping my eyes on the road and being
a perfect citizen because as an Asian in
media I can't be a bad driver
straight up I think I'm the best drive
to try guys I'm gonna say it there I
said it
now that stop sign is a distraction I
will not be fooled oh that's great how
fun was that the course is divided into
four tiers first it's phone based
distractions texting calling the
challenge will be to not look at your
phone oh my second yeah oh yeah second
the rest of the track guys are gonna get
in a car with us and try and distract us
level three will be a personal
distraction which means all of us have
chosen different distractions for each
other and the final tier random mystery
explosive craziness
and we're off new text from Zack
Kornfeld to hear it they listen listen
love your body here's the message butts
butts butts net is sexy say your message
jeez I can't talk right now
send all right don't get distracted nor
the text messages Hey look at those
handsome men always slow down when you
see handsome max it's amazing me without
bands no I'm looking not looking nope
not gonna look eight signs better
fantastic keep saying I'm not interested
in your with the brain ladies say what
do you want that hey Eugene you're so
freaking late can you please hurry up
what no wait I'm gonna sign did you
check backseat what they know that
spelling my name wrong is that oh oh oh
that's disgusting
hey baby girl watch me take this turn
hey baby girl now I've got to learn how
to drive this car so that losing my mind
it's my friend I'm sick this camera
okay so Zach always rolls in the
meetings with three guys don't touch
Eugene's hair you know you guys don't
like that net you gotta stay focused
or wash out of the car
[Music]
holy no no no actually I got it
this is a nice can you bring one up here
I went off course a little bit I saw my
wife in a cage and nothing else matters
you can't waste buckets of fried chicken
no no no also that bucket was almost
entirely chicken breasts like the gold
of the chicken when the chicken was
placed on the road well that's unsaved I
got out of the car to remove the
obstruction in the roadway I assessed
myself as having a very high level of
focus I tested with a high level of
focus but when I went on the course and
there was a clown in my back seat
everything when out the window do you at
least in the name I can call you bye
great ok quiet clapping awesome and
final stretch entering the mysteries
slippery when wet oh boy they are there
[Music]
you having a ride get in what do you
guys do for a living why did they pick a
carnival Oh what is this what is this
what is it so I won that's exciting I
don't think anyone saw that coming I did
I always had faith in the closet filled
up come in last place Oh last place even
though scientifically I had the best
attention span I was still distracted
even though I won I don't think any of
us really won we all messed up live
driving is about winning it's about not
losing
not everyone has killer backseat clowns
but really if you think about your cell
phone it's pretty much the same thing
you never know what kind of distractions
can come your way you can't control how
you react to them
no I'm not gonna hug the clouds why is
everyone making me hug
okay thanks clown all right bye